Darroch Greer, Filmmaker: The budget was in the end million dollars
and it was a million dollars Fred Rouse
our advisor we met with him early on and
he said "So you're talking about a
million dollar picture?" and I said "Oh no no no no I I think three hundred, three
hundred fifty thousand dollars."  And and I
remember think it'd be about two years
maybe two and a half years and but
because of the fundraising and because
the movie kept getting bigger it took us
seven years and in the end Fred was
exactly right and it was a million
dollars. Ron King, Filmmaker: Yeah, I mean I would think that
our film for the budget that we ended up
spending on it was probably a big
bargain because you know we did a lot of
the shoots with very very small crew
like one in some cases one person and
and then when we did get to New Zealand
we were flying with helicopters and
airplanes and all of that everybody who
was involved in that gave us lots of
discounts so you know I think it's more
of a two million dollar movie that got
made for a million dollars that's that's
why I like to think about it
but in the end what did that teach you
about raising money for a movie because
I know looking back on at seven years
prior do you think you actually would
have said yes to it knowing it wasn't
just gonna be a few years it wasn't just
gonna be three hundred thousand and all
that's gone on what do you think you
would have said yes I I've often
wondered about that because it would
seem very daunting but but the film grew
in such an organic way and and really we
never flagged I mean that you know there
was some times that were discouraging
and sometimes we're just out of money
and nothing was really happening but you
know having a partner passing the ball
back and forth and I was always
interested in the next thing we were
going to do I mean and we learned so
much I had I had done documentaries for
television but I had never done the
whole thing soup-to-nuts myself and from
the research which I really loved at the
writing to to actually shooting
airplanes and I went to Europe for five
weeks and shot there and went along the
Western Front and over the English
Channel and then
the movie just kept getting bigger and
bigger and more exciting and so there'd
be another hurdle and not enough we
always felt up for it
yeah I mean my sense throughout making
the movie was it was one of those ones
of sort of focus and also never taking
really never taking no for an answer
it's sort of like you have to be so
dedicated that you're you know people
are telling you no you can't do that
you're never gonna be able to do that
and you basically in your own mind and
in your own spirit
you basically say yes I can do that and
I'm going to do that you know I mean so
it's one of those things of believing in
the project and that you will accomplish
it and finish it that was always there
even when we were at the low points that
Derek mentioned there's still this thing
that's saying this movie is going to get
completed we are going to finish it
we're gonna follow through and I think
that if filmmakers keep that sort of
mindset as they work on their films it
it will get you get you to where you
want to go you just have to believe that
it's going to happen and keep following
that vision and it is persistence it
really is just showing up I mean there
were times when Ron and I would fly to
New York you know to meet some people to
go to a dinner party and come back with
nothing and but you know the cumulative
effect of being there and going on and
you know having a bit to show for the
effort you put in you know finally pays
off and again as I as I said earlier the
film the film evolves you know and it
are often documentary filmmakers get
setbacks and they don't have the money
to edit or continue the film but that
time allows the story not only to grow
and maybe change but also to gestate and
then you come up with a much fuller and
richer film yeah yeah and the other
piece for young filmmakers or other
people starting out is I would just say
it's
start making the movie it doesn't matter
like if you have one picture and you're
making a documentary make a 30-second
video with that one picture with a
voiceover and maybe a little bit of
music behind it but demonstrate that you
can actually make something because
that's the thing that worked for us we
made little pieces of the movie over
time and we would show those pieces to
people and then people would finally say
oh oh you guys can actually make a movie
as opposed to just pitching an idea
because you don't have to have a lot of
resources to make a very simple piece
that will speak to your vision and what
you're trying to do you know so mate
start making the movie that's that's my
suggestion I completely agree with that
and there are two schools of thought
about that I've worked on other projects
where they said no we should we should
get all the money together first and you
know and then we won't be left hanging
and we'll we will know that we can do
this and and you know and I think you
have to prove yourself I mean I don't
know
Ken Burns doesn't have to or you know
very experienced filmmakers but you know
documentary films are curious individual
projects and they often don't work out
the way you've originally thought and so
yeah I think it's important to just
start working and sorry how far were you
into the process when you actually got
FedEx onboard as a sponsor FedEx the the
story with FedEx is that we were six
years in Wow we got an invitation to
screen the film at Ash Kosh which is the
largest air show in the United States
and we said yes to that even though we
didn't have a finished film and we
didn't have the finishing funds either
so this was this was one of those times
where we said yeah we'll be there we'll
have the movie we can screen it and then
we were like okay how the heck are we
gonna do this let's call Fred Smith
that's when finally our fundraising team
broke down and said yes let's and we had
been trying to reach out to fat
over time but finally it broke through
right at the moment that we needed them
and they came in at the very last minute
to save us basically so that we could
finish the film for oshkosh so again
showing up it sounds like you were
planning to go there too regardless yeah
even if you were going to show a little
trailer we made the commitment but yeah
but they helped us out at the end
you